so I started small with dev tools open
so I get the resolution and I pulled the
page out alright that's about 680 pixels
and I think this still looks good so
let's make it a little bit larger Here I
am at about 815 pixels
still I think that looks good I think I
can go larger okay now I'm at 11:30 okay
this is definitely way too large for
here let's pull it back in a little bit
around 850 pixels or so I think I'm
about at my limit for how wide I want
this image to be and for how far apart I
want these elements to be so for my
answer I put 850 pixels but really like
I said this is an art not a science so
if you didn't get the same answer as me
that's totally fine this isn't the right
answer but you know it's what I think